i want to be really clear because there
are a lot of people who who sort of
you know get by on on social media drama
and it's there's a throttling and
there's a counter claim look
we've had false copyright claims we've
never lost on those right half asian
lawyer bill richmond
we've filed counter claims we've had to
file petitions of information in the
past
this is very different this is the big
one we filed an official notice
uh uh that we are filing a lawsuit with
youtube and an immediate motion for um
an injunction in
conjunctive relief because we have two
strikes in our account right now
and we have good reason to believe that
there may be a third
one that they're looking for
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is a
man on youtube
i think kinda maybe stephen crowder
welcome back yeah no i i depends on when
this is exactly
running uh two-week suspension from
youtube
right from the second hard strike so not
on youtube right now but
you know once upon a time the biggest
right-leaning channel ever in the
history of the platform
okay so let's be clear about what's
going on here this is an emergency
meeting
of the reuben crowder thing
because you could be booted you now have
two strikes on your channel channel i'll
let you go into why you got the strikes
but in essence if you get one more
strike if you even
sniff near susan wajeski
that's it your entire channel your
catalog the entire thing your business
gone yeah yeah the business the the 12
to 15 people that i employ
uh gone and by the way that means within
only a
series of a few months you and all other
right-leaning people as well because
let's be clear here
uh i talked about michael knows with
this i'm basic [ __ ] pumpkin spice
conservatism i mean you know it's not
like anything that i really believe is
all that radical and i've been here
think of you as basic [ __ ] yeah i i
really am and it's okay it's a moniker
that i wear proudly nothing about me is
very radical i'm pro second amendment
i'm pro first amendment i'm pro-ending
the drug war
i believe in uh things like heartbeat
bills with abortion it's pretty much
conservative christian who advocated
that people not have sex until they're
married i know
crazy keep me away from the kids but i
want to be really clear because there
are a lot of people who
who sort of you know get by on on social
media drama and it's there's a
throttling and there's a counter claim
look
we've had false copyright claims we've
never lost on those right i'm half asian
lawyer bill richmond
we've filed counter claims we've had to
file petitions of information in the
past
this is very different this is the big
one we filed an official notice
uh uh that we are filing a lawsuit with
youtube and an immediate motion for
an injunction injunctive relief because
we have two strikes in our account right
now
uh and we have good reason to believe
that there may be a third
one that they're looking for how do i
know this because
they're just waiting right and because
it's not very clear
i should say it is very clear that we
didn't violate specific policies
uh and so they said well maybe the
totality of in tandem so if people want
to know and by the way
people can still watch us uh we're
available at mug club you know in blaze
lottery credit.com club and
we always recommend that people join
anyways because there's an hour worth of
extra content every day
but we're still making sure that the
free content is available on apple on
android spotify
and right now on rumble though we can't
stream live it's a little glitchy we're
working with them
but um you know the issue here with
youtube to give an idea on a couple of
strikes
the first one that came in was a warning
that was supposed to be a heart strike
uh on uh voter fraud now i have never
said that uh
donald trump won the election that the
ghost of hugo chavez
you know ring rigged smartmatic uh and
and
whisked away wisconsin uh but just like
amy klobuchar just like elizabeth warren
just like jimmy carter
i said that individual voter fraud does
occur and of course
as they said it occurs far more with
mass mail in voting
just because there are fewer checks and
balances there are fewer ways to sort of
verify
and so the segment that we did was
almost comical in us saying
you know not that there's anything wrong
with that thing not that there's any
vote fraud but we cross-reference voter
roles
with addresses that didn't exist on
google earth sent interns with a copy of
that day's paper
at an empty lot on camera live to say
look
we know that it occurs i think it might
have been 30 or 40 addresses
they said that's a violation of the
election fraud policy
okay the second one was wait wait can i
pause you there because i think just
sort of philosophically
and i don't want to get myself booted
now too but right
we're not even addressing the
philosophic issue which is should you be
allowed to just say what you want to say
in a free country
right you know a supposedly open
platform and everything else i mean it's
just worth mentioning that that
you're you're saying you didn't break
the rules but the the question really is
are the rules just completely insane
no absolutely and by the way we were
never told that we were wrong too to be
clear no one is no one has
proven a matter of fact we got fact
checked and some people said that we
were wrong when really
the fact check ended up being they
changed the voter rolls the the next
night to a new address that didn't exist
that was one that was part of a series
so
i don't want to get too off into the
weeds there but these were things where
we did our due diligence to a comical
degree
that was the point of this segment the
first actual strike i believe i don't
remember the exact sequence was
coveted 15 uh 15 days to flatten the
curve a one year anniversary
now what did we do we showed them cdc
saying don't wear masks say wear masks
don't wear double masks wear double
masks we won't have a vaccine in a year
i wouldn't take the vaccine if it was
done in a year take the vaccine all of
this stuff right
which is really tough to navigate as an
american from what i understand the
statement that was a violation
was something to be effective because i
don't want you to get booted something
to the effect
of the covet is significantly more
lethal to old people
we know that we need to figure out how
to protect the most vulnerable but for
some reason due to the immune response
according to the cdc and we always list
our references available on our website
young people uh are significantly less
at risk of death from kova than the flu
for some reason young but old people
it's way more deadly
we use the cdc mortality tables we've
been given a specific reason as to what
the violation is but the time
code that i believe were given was where
that statement was made and people can
we're the only show i know of
if you go to lydewithcrowder.com every
single episode has a page
with the references the references for
that statement were the cdc and world
health organization
now some people can say well you're
making it seem like it's not as big of
it
people may not take it seriously well a
that's not what i'm saying and b
if we're going to follow the science
it's important to understand how
different immune systems respond to a
novel
virus it's important that you don't tell
people shut up if they have a problem
with a two-year-old wearing a mask
if you say well hold on a second we
don't have two or four-year-olds wear a
mask for the flu
where there are significantly more
deaths for younger people it is
significantly deadlier for older
people or the immuno compromise you're
not allowed to discuss that the most
recent one this is the second strike
here
this is why there's a lawsuit which i
really didn't want this to have to come
to i would just want to do the show
is when i was recently celebrating
actually praising the officer who saved
that young girl's life who was about to
be stabbed by mackay bryant
i said not only is that justified from
the police
i believe it's necessary because if the
police cannot shoot someone who is in
the process of attempting to stab
you then we might as well not have
police and i believe that we should have
police
that was considered bullying and
harassment but not technically
but the totality may be over time
indicative of bullying harassing by
supporting the police
who is that bullying who are you
bullying by saying that
you supported the cops saving a woman's
life who was about to be decapitated
who was that bullying apparently it
might be considered reveling in in the
death of
mackay bryant i don't know we don't have
an official answer yeah and we can't get
these official answers from people at
youtube
but let me just be really clear with
people out there this is tantamount to
saying to everyone out there if you're
conservative we don't want you look if
they are saying
hey look you cannot discuss the
mortality rates of cobalt you cannot
point out that the cdc has been
inconsistent and confusing which has
made it harder for americans to stay
safe
you are not allowed to say that voter
fraud has ever occurred
to any degree and you are not allowed to
support police
if they save someone's life mid-stabbing
if the person committing the stabbing
happens to be
a girl of color that is saying you are
not welcome on this platform
if you hold these views now if they say
that that's fine the issue there is i'm
pro-business
i'm anti-fraud youtube says all views
are welcome
those strikes without description tell
us otherwise
we need to know the rule book because
people's livelihoods
depend on it well crowder you know last
week i put up an interview
with david horowitz i'm sure you know
david horowitz and i've
never in in all of my years of doing
this show i've never edited for content
except one time
i had a guest come on who was drunk and
stoned and we ended up editing
just to basically save this person's
career it's the only time we've edited
for
i did that once too we can compare notes
off there this person was doing crack
in the laundry room no joke yeah he was
probably the same person
but uh but last week for the first time
we edited for content because david
horowitz a free man in what i thought
was a free country
dared to say two sentences that i knew
my channel could be deleted
like that so we had to we censored it on
youtube i mean simple as that i put it
up in my locals community
but now i'm having you you crazy right
wing maniac well you're such a tease i
know i want to hear the two sentences
and that's the issue right what's going
to happen is of course all people want
to hear the sentences
and they assume that it's like not
seeing the monster in a scary movie you
assume that it's worse than it is
that's how you radicalize people when
you see these new york times articles
saying
hey radicalization it has a picture with
me next to philip defranco
and then by the way hey i was in there
come on were you in there too
that's right yeah i just you know again
i would never imagine that you would be
in there
radicalizing people dave reuben
incredible
man but what happens is then they
complain about echo chambers right well
look
what's more radical a view of someone
who believes what the guy who believes
in a flat tax or the people who believe
in 90 income tax the guy who believes
that police need to be demilitarized to
a degree but that they also need to be
able to do their job and they should
wear body cams or the people who believe
we should have no police whatsoever we
should have no prisons whatsoever
like rashida tlape like aoc like these
people believe this is not a radical
point of view
this the reason for this lawsuit is look
you know could i uh uh at some point
sail off under the sunset with support
from people at mud club
i don't know further but at some point i
could but what about the next kid
who wants to start a business you know i
started this in 2009 maybe 2008 with a
blue bed sheet behind me
i don't see a world in which their point
of view is even allowed to be expressed
and we talk about othering people
youtube is othering an entire half of
the country and by the way
more than 80 of black people while we're
talking about
the mackay bryant and that officer
situation more than 80 black people want
at least as much of a police presence as
exists now
if not more and because that isn't a
view that is permissible on
we silence these minorities too we host
people under look
if the guy who did change my mind which
was
antithetical to the you know sort of
24-hour news
cycle if it bleeds it leads if that's
removed as impermissible
no conservative viewpoint is permissible
on youtube well i think you know crowder
i don't think i'm enlightening you when
i tell you that you know that what this
really of course is about is that you
are changing minds you have an
absolutely extraordinarily huge channel
how many people did you have on election
night before they took you down how many
people were watching
oh gosh i don't uh i don't know it was
it was at any given
point something like six hundred
thousand cumulative it was like 16
million you know and look
i hate doing this because you know no
you know that we've had people who do i
get it it's not it's not just
it's not just blowing you up but but the
point is yeah
why are they always trying to take out
tucker i mean we know why it's not about
tucker
it's about the people yeah it's about
billions of plays
billions of plays across our platform
and if you include it's it's one of
those things and i say it on my knees
i'm so grateful for it and i know that
all this could go away and i could annoy
people and they don't want to watch the
show
that's fine but it needs to occur on an
honest platform an important thing too a
lot of people think this doesn't affect
them they go well he's a dick
like guilty however if you're a business
owner
you want to conduct business now in the
21st century this is a town square
230 not even withstanding but you know
this youtube
twitter facebook they co they go to
business owners they come to us and say
advertise with us
you get to keep the subscribers you gain
if you advertise you get to keep the
followers that you gain right if you
want to open up a shop and you don't
advertise online
you haven't got a shot and this is an
issue of dishonest business practices if
they are choosing
not only politically winners and losers
as it relates to business they can do
this with
anyone i'm pro-business i'm anti-fraud
and with youtube right now here's the
issue you have what
you have community guidelines okay
that's one set of rules that's set by
youtube
youtube says advertiser friendly
guidelines are set by sponsors well i've
tried to be a sponsor and i've
advertised i've never once been
requested hey where would you like to
advertise your content
matter of fact they've precluded me from
doing it and i've been a content creator
where i can't accept
certain sponsors and then they have a
third category which no one really knows
isn't defined which is borderline
and we don't know who determines that
they're all determined by youtube at the
end of the day yes
yes borderline dave rubin the
radicalization the uh
the third reich mr rubin
you know the funny thing about that
article in the new york times about the
radicalization to the to the far right
is yeah you
and defranco and jordan peterson and
milton friedman who's a real nutbag
uh you guys were all on the cover of the
print one you had to open to page three
to get my picture except it was a huge
picture of my face under something like
leading them to the alt-right
my dad had no idea my dad had no idea
but wait
putting aside the specifics of the
politics and i get it people
people know that you don't want the
government involved and they know you
they get the difference between platform
and publisher and all that stuff
just on the pure like you're suing
youtube side of this it can't be that
much fun i think i sort of asked you
about that last time like like the idea
that you're going
up against goliath like it's not like a
great pleasure
no it's it's not something that i want
to do at all and i wish it could be
settled and i wish that we could have
had answers and look i just want to do
my show
unlike you know with joe rogan for
example in spotify uh something like 40
something episodes were removed and it
was done in the dead of night look
this is why we haven't do it though just
for the record i mean right
now to be clear that what happened with
the vox apocalypse
um there were conversations behind the
scenes which hopefully i have to be
careful as to what i discuss what i
don't but we were very public we said
look
we have to remove 30-something videos
from youtube because they may be
borderline even though they're not
violating policy
these are available at mug club didn't
want to do it it wasn't a violation of
policies but i was saying hey
this is an act of good faith it's
youtube sandbox they can determine the
rules and we were transparent about
saying
off platform at mug club and you know
these might have been radical views like
life begins at you know conception or
something like that something that
should never be permissible on youtube
we were very straightforward with it our
entire catalog has been audited
at great length and now these are new
potential violations that may or may not
exist
look we've had to reinvent this is why i
say i'm about to be a father of two
i employ i think it's 14 people right
now
um and that you know this these are the
first people that i think of when i when
i get up and the last people i think of
when i go to sleep
because they don't have the control that
i do in fighting youtube and making
these decisions my decisions affect them
we've had to fundamentally change our
business model and we figured out
oh wait if you search stephen crowder
change my mind abortion you find an old
pbs video with 400 views
we can no longer rely on search or
browse okay we're going to focus on
not just subscriptions but notifications
wait notifications no longer really work
so we moved to a live show we can't edit
because we go live
and we just tell people and it still
isn't mug club weekdays at 10 a.m
eastern
to the point where it doesn't matter if
we don't show up in search
it doesn't matter if we don't show up
and browse it doesn't matter if
subscriptions or notifications work
we have a baseline of millions of
viewers who will tune in every day
and we're always at the top of the
youtube live page right
they can't control it because it's more
popular than other programs
i think this is sort of the last
decision they can make
considering that we've consistently
adapted to rules that are not applied to
anyone else
i am so i am such a pacifist i
sow him a conflict avoider but my belief
is
you avoid avoid avoid avoid avoid and
then if you have to engage in a conflict
you make it as swift and effective as
you possibly can
and i wish that we hadn't crossed that
line i wish that youtube hadn't
i hope they do the right thing and i
don't want to do this but we will
have you ever met susan the ceo of
youtube have you ever met her
never which is bizarre when you see her
mentioning me by name at the recode
conference with
someone who works for vox interviewing
her it's it's surreal it really is
was that the interview where they said
dave rubin is the gateway drug to guys
like steven crowder i think that might
have been it
is that is that i'm not kidding i'm not
kidding there was one talk
i don't know if it was that one you were
that you were the molly to my mdma
i don't know maybe it could be but it's
bizarre for me
to do molly first or well i honestly i
don't know
basic [ __ ] like i said i don't know um
let me ask you one more thing because
we're just doing this quick because i
just wanted to get word out about this
because it's important because thank you
the truth is i mean we're friends but
the truth is if you go down
then you're right it's the floodgates on
everybody but so let me just ask you
this to finish
do you sort of feel like this with you
and youtube
is just directly connected to everything
going on in society right now which is
that all the things that guys like us
have been screaming about and warning
against
it's all here it's at the doorstep
that's sort of what you were saying like
it's just like
it's all just arrived and whether it's
crowd or being taken off youtube or
attacking people in the streets or
changing every norm in our
political discourse it's all here
look people need to understand the world
that we live laws are being suspended
what do i mean
right now you have people complaining
like there are laws in florida that if
it will just make it easy for you to run
over protesters i go ah it's like oh
it's like what we're talking about our
riots are talking about people have been
dragged out of their cars
hold on is it illegal to congregate
in the middle of a freeway it is it's
illegal but
but we've just decided we don't enforce
those laws so we've decided to suspend
the law and instead turn
americans into criminals americans with
vehicles americans who legally purchase
firearms we've decided to turn them into
criminals now maybe americans
who speak out against policies turn them
into criminals i will i will say this
look with
with with youtube um you know go back to
the idea of publisher platform
i don't think it's ever been more clear
than uh to use twitter as an example i
mean donald president donald trump
wasn't really on youtube
they remove a sitting president for
saying fight like hell
and look i don't care i don't even think
it's controversial anyone who acts as a
fight like hell has not been a phrase
that has been used as
as a colloquialism for is being
intellectually dishonest that's why we
sell the fight like hell shirt at
crowder shop um it's a term that i've
seen waters has said worse
yes she has said worse and she's done
worse look at the size of those pupils
uh so he was removed though twitter said
that's a bridge too far okay
the ayatollah khamenei is still still on
twitter hamas is still on twitter
who a part of their charter is not by
the way not just the eradication of
israel
all jews and we're also we're talking
about anti-semitic hate crimes that
could potentially be inspired by donald
trump here at home
look that is an editorial decision in
other words if twitter says
this is too far for donald trump to be
on twitter or youtube or facebook
that means that they are consciously
saying hamas is not too far
the ayatollah not too far and that
cannot come
with the same legal protections of a
platform
like at t or verizon that is an
editorial decision
just like the new york times just like
the washington post and just like
youtube saying
you can't praise an officer for saving a
girl's life from being stabbed
we can't allow it can't allow that to go
on isn't it a weird position
that for guys like us like i do think
about it often where i'm like man
if if youtube servers blew up but i
think about it usually more related to
twitter if twitter just
ceased to exist tomorrow and all the
data was destroyed
all of the followings all of that stuff
like it feels to me and i actually don't
mean this on the youtube side on the
twitter side specifically
like the world would be better that's a
very weird thing
for guys like to think yeah i know but
you know i don't know about youtube
because where would people find their
hardcore pornography
we have found by the way just just so
people know hardcore
on youtube yes yes and there's also guys
who play uh
listen we've done this on the show
dickerdildo it's two uh two uh
uh homosexual gentlemen who put up a
sheet and played dick or dildo where the
guy is facing the camera
and he has to guess if it's a dick or a
dildo by the way the answer is always
dick it's never dildo this is on youtube
and it's not even age restricted
now i will say this i know look and
people know that i don't i'm not trying
to shock people
when we cite facts when we give out
references they're all publicly
available on the website i don't know
any other show that does that you're
talking about on average
anywhere from 40 to 60 per day
we make a joke it may offend people you
may not find it funny you may not like
it but you have to acknowledge that it's
a joke and the standard can't be
does it offend you the standard that
youtube has to apply and i'm going to
use some language here because i'm
quoting directly stephen colbert and
samantha b
is did steven do anything did steven
crowder say anything more offensive than
referring to a sitting president's mouth
as putin's [ __ ] holster did he say did
he bully anyone worse than samantha bee
with a national platform on
on television referring to the first
lady as a feckless [ __ ] nope
that's the standard that has to be
applied equally not if it offends
somebody and because that's not the kind
of language or spirit of the comedy
that i would ever use facts and
information notwithstanding
well crowder i just want to say that
it's been nice knowing you
and susan if you're watching
um i didn't want to do this i was forced
into it because
crowder's very influential and
threatened me and
this has been a hostage situation and
i'm so sorry to
have this discussion about free speech
and open discourse
crowder final word should have never
given me uh access to your
to your icloud so they're gonna expect
many more of these interviews if i'm
deep platformed i'll be lording over
that you forever
no look i appreciate it and like i said
this is uh
if i thought it was just about our pl
just about our channel you know it
wouldn't be that big a deal i really do
i'm afraid that there won't be these
opportunities for anybody else
uh out there who have an alternative
point of view when we talk about the
young kid who's bullied
i think of the young kid right now who
grew up in this pandemic era
where their parents are punished if they
even speak out with an alternative
opinion let alone what they see on
social media and people's lives
destroyed
and now as a matter of potentially
official policy
combined with a culture that is designed
to completely remove the idea of right
and wrong but only seeing
the the general through the lens of the
oppressed and the oppressor and turn
everyone into good little rule followers
without questioning whether the rules
are just
or if they're applied justly i'm really
scared for that and that's why we're
doing
so we filed this official uh
notification of a lawsuit
i don't want to do it but i just don't
see any other way unless they get their
get their button gear
crowder joking aside you know i'm
completely with you on this i will
support you in any way
you can we are we are proxies for a lot
of people
in this crazy thing and you're huge
right now and they want to make an
example of you
i will fight with you till the end man
but thank you sir
because what was this what was the other
youtube channel dickerdildo yeah okay
all right see you later
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about comedy
instead of the non-stop yelling you get
everywhere else check out our comedy
playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics check out our
full episode playlist they're both
right over here and to get notified of
all future videos be sure to subscribe
and click the notification bell